a lot of people are worried that this
might cost the election for Trump hmm
now hold on man
if by July this ends we are gonna see
the biggest market rally in the history
of this country
definitely and then Trump's gonna
autograph the thing again yeah you know
he autographed it on Friday and then
Monday it's like bull crash is the worst
crash ever so for timing mm-hmm but say
I come June July when this is over and
confidence comes back it is gonna be a
massive and insane rally it's like
people are gonna become rich overnight
like he's gonna make so many
millionaires I agree and then just the
thought of it's a I didn't say Biden
wins Trump vs. Biden onstage dude like
Trump's gonna rip him apart you know
even if the market collapsed completely
and we were in like Mad Max territory
even if Bernie was trump gonna lose -
right just listen to them both talk the
other day was just like here's here's
they're just yelling at each other
the craziest thing to me is that right
now we are being told by all of our
local governments to bunker down don't
go out shut these businesses down and
then Biden and Bernie had the nerve to
go on stage and say if you come here you
will not under any circumstances be held
accountable you will not be deported and
then burn even and when I say and I will
give you free health care so ho hold on
hold on hold on you're telling me our
beds are overrun the ICU is ours our
capacity and we better stay inside not
go to the movies not buy food and just
hide from 8:00 p.m. to 5 to 5 in the
morning and then you want to let in all
these other people to use our ICU beds
that we don't have dude if you want to
get me you want to get me swearing on
streem this is the clothes I'll bet take
a breath don't you tell me I can't go
outside because we're facing medical
system capacity and then you're gonna
tell these people who are not in our
country not citizens not taxpayers they
get access to our medical system this is
where we're being stretched to the limit
you're right and they had the nerve in
the midst of a crisis where they had no
audience because of the crisis both of
them saying we're not gonna deport
anybody and if they come to the hospital
you're good to go
dude you know what you're right and now
I'm really mad so things I'm so mad whoo
I am I am sitting in my house we can't
go to the movies
we can't go to the mall I can't go out
and get a nice meal with you guys get a
burger at a local shop but they're gonna
go on TV in front of everyone in America
and say so
Governor Cuomo got on TV yesterday and
said that the ICU with 80% fault just
from the normal ICU stuff going on in
New York City nothing to do with corona
exactly so normal natural normal when I
worked in the hospital the ICU was
constantly full we would get patients
too early patients who shouldn't have
been moved yet sometimes they would have
to go back but they needed the beds so
this is how they run hospitals and
Governor Cuomo was talking about again
today and and we only have 20% of the
hospital beds in New York are the ICU
beds in New York to make this happen and
they're talking on TV this is such bad
optics for them to get up there and talk
about free healthcare for illegal people
I got a message from someone saying that
one of their family members has cancer
and was turned away for follow-up
treatment saying you can get your
follow-up treatment at a later time we
need the beds right now for coronavirus
patients that's amazing so you're gonna
tell me this someone's gonna show up to
a hospital not a citizen illegal illegal
immigrant you're saying they refuse to
be helped you you Biden said you will
not under any circumstance be held
accountable that's a really weird way to
say it - yeah it's like you knew what
they did was wrong you're gonna put that
person in one of our beds weep we pay
for through all the through everything
we do and then when my neighbors dad is
dying of cancer
you're gonna say you can't come because
this person who's not from here came
here illegally and we're gonna let him
have that bed yeah I was you want to
Center myself a liberal and I'm just
being pushed what dude dude is this the
right side of the screen yeah but this
isn't a conservative position it's not
and it should just be exactly it's that
liberals used to the liberal position is
is community based but it's not
socialist open borders right what what
Bernie and Biden are doing right now is
is I don't know how to describe it other
than chaotic pandering psychosis
yeah the pan doing the reason why I call
it psychosis is a bit hyper
but look at this way there's literally
no logic in Bernie Sanders statements
where he said the globalization policies
have backfired it's a national security
threat in a statement he said what's
happened with China has been a disaster
but then he goes on and say we're not
gonna deport you it's we're gonna
decriminalize border crossings and give
you access to our health care how can
you simultaneously call out the problem
of globalization
how can Bernie Sanders only a year ago
say not even a year ago he didn't
interview the New York Times where he
said illegal immigrants depress wages
and hurt the American worker and then he
has the nerve to go on TV and say this
it is paradoxical he is contradicting
himself because he doesn't actually have
principles he's standing on he's trying
to manipulate people for votes and this
is why he lost me in 2015 when Bernie
said open borders his coke brothers
proposal I said wow it was talking about
unions working class he said second
amendment rural versus urban there's a
big argument I said Wow Bernie that's
great argument yeah I remember like
being all into Bernie back then and it
doesn't it's like he's you know so
slowly like polarized each of his
different points that he keeps bringing
it up because they're very similar he
keeps bringing up the same stuff over
and over and over again but they're
they're being changed little by little
over the even Biden men yeah Biden's now
saying moratorium on all deportations
they're being pushed in this direction
and I'm like the craziest thing to me
I'll quote bill bill maher he said when
who was it Elizabeth Warren I think
wasn't warning she said that she was
gonna have oh no no I wasn't warned he
said that they were catering to they're
trying to pass a policy to get
transgender prison inmates to vote and
he was like why are you going after that
voting demographic of 452 people yeah so
when you see here's what I see with Bert
with Bernie and Biden why are you
pandering to a demographic that can't
vote yeah it doesn't make they're not
American voters who are you talking or
they shouldn't I already I already have
this issue with universal health health
care because I don't want to pay for
people who don't take care of themselves
you nandi concern that they need help I
I'm a healthy person I I do a lot of
research on what I consume what I eat
and that's really important I brushed my
teeth you know a lot of people don't
a lot of people don't care and just
waste away and then they need treatment
and then it's like they're saying that I
have to pay for that I'm I'm finding
ivis
I have an easy easy analogy hmm we've
got a bunch of we had to get some trees
taken down because they were they're on
the verge of falling over there were
diseases to the other were yeah so we'd
take him down it was kind of sad I hate
to see trees go and so you've been
chopping that a bit mmm now imagine the
neighbors were like we're cold so we're
taking your wood you're like well first
of all those were our trees yeah we paid
to remove them mm-hmm because there
that's it's sad we regret it you know to
a certain degree and now we've done the
work to actually get the firewood yeah
and then they say share the firewood
that's that's literally what it is yeah
basically people who did no no not even
that it's uh people coming from other
countries going oh yeah well we're gonna
we need this also yeah it's like a bunch
of people from a town over coming over
here and being like not even my
neighbors yeah yeah literally people
that that don't even know me so here
here's my ugly give up the neighbors
they're pretty nice shout out to our
neighbors
I look at conservative and liberal from
what they've always been and what
happens is because many conservatives
have always called leftists liberals
they've kits been conflated yeah I take
issue with that because liberals and
conservatives agree on a ton I think
social programs are a good thing yeah I
agree for Americans in certain
situations I I think you know we as
Americans are all part of a community
that takes care of each other and we're
I'm totally on board with immigration
people should be able to come here and
apply and do all that stuff we're based
on and then once you're in welcome to
the club you've got we got benefits for
you just like everybody else but one
other what they're proposing now is not
liberal policy it is insane illogical
policy that cannot exist and it doesn't
make sense
Bernie can't tell you how much it costs
for Medicare for all tack on all of the
illegal immigrants the there's a million
last year who would now want access to
our medical system which many of them
still get and it's like how do you pay
for that especially in time of global
pandemic when we're at our capacity they
are begging us to flatten the curve
that's what they're saying right we got
to flatten the curve guys if too many
people get sick at one
our medical system will be overloaded
now while we're flattening the curve
we're gonna decriminalize border
crossings and grant access to all these
immigrants to our health care system so
you guys take responsibility and
under-the-radar we're just gonna do all
this stuff that you had no say in runnin
some socialism some ubi and free health
care for illegals emergency socialism
stoked emergency socialist yeah super
chance a we're super tight
I mean well we basically just we did a
little I mean there's been a lot going
on today I know I guess we got it we got
a lot out huh yeah let's let's read some
more supertunia let's get back to it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you